sienna you've spoken uh very openly and
vulnerably about this being sort of
familiar terrain to you and i wondered
what the most difficult part of that was
to play something that brings up your
own personal memories you know i think i
just i just remember those moments when
the tabloid media was really intense and
really rife and there was very little
agency that young women had over their
own lives and the telling of their
stories and and you know getting the
call one evening um that something was
coming out in the press the following
day and it had gone to print and there's
nothing you can do about it and it's
intensely personal and painful and
everyone's gonna know
it's a horrible horrible feeling that i
and many others experienced um in the
earliest part of my career so it was
uncomfortable to revisit that space at
the same time from a slightly what feels
like tourism perspective interesting
because it feels like
another lifetime and many many years ago
and the world is so different now that i
i was interested to go back and sit in
that space and perhaps recalibrate the
memory in some way of some of those
events
were you able to was it cathartic or
therapeutic in any way what were the
takeaways you know my heart started
beating really fast in one scene and the
monitor that i had on for the sound
picked it up
and they've actually kept my
accelerating heartbeat um as a motive
throughout the show and certainly in
that scene
so it's funny that the body remembers
these kind of traumatic events um
but of course there's catharsis in all
of it i often find going to work and
getting to cry or explore things
psychologically is just i go home a bit
lighter i mean it's free therapy
sometimes isn't it
it was just
sex
nothing's just sex
there's more
you're not telling me just to tell me
to unburden yourself
the story's about to break first of all
this show is so good i can't tell you
how fast i watched it the script is
incredible themes of infidelity of abuse
of power of what the real truth is so
much to get into but what drew each of
you to the project why did you want to
do this show i loved big little lies and
the undoing and the creative team behind
those shows were behind this show i got
sent a pile of six scripts which is
really daunting and i was sort of
dreading sitting down to read them and
then couldn't stop and so i realized
that if we unless we've made a complete
mess of things it should be something
that people really want to watch and
it's just exciting to not only make
something that's compelling and
propulsive in the way that this is also
really looking at the themes that you
mentioned you know privilege and consent
and and and all of those things which
just added up to make it more
substantial than just something you know
compelling it's quite thought-provoking
yes
rupert's like she nailed that yeah i was
gonna say i mean that's i mean i would
all of that plus for me it was the idea
of trying to play a character who when i
read him i really really didn't like him
at all he was the kind of guy that i
just steer well clear of
so you know that that was an interesting
challenge to wrap my head around you
mentioned the great david e kelly's
shows
they all have these great the mystery
and the thought-provoking moments and
then the great homes and the woman with
a glass of wine in her hand
yeah did it feel cool to say i'm
drinking the wine i'm doing it this is
that iconic scene because wow they have
a great home piece too i mean the most
beautiful home i actually drink from the
bottle in one scene which i did add on
the day i was like she deserves it she
deserves it after everything she's been
through today wait i loved that moment
you improvised that well yeah i just
said i want you know there's a moment in
the book where she swings from the
bottle and it wasn't in the script and i
loved it so much because i can
understand just that sienna likes to
bring something of herself to each role
that she plays and i think that drinking
from the bottle is something that most
people don't have much experience of
fortunately sienna was able to english
it's a
[Laughter]
oh there was one very very smelly wine
um i i still to this day think you put
that in there i do but it was it was it
the wine bottle i opened and it was like
it was smelled like that
it was like a used toilet and then i
made everyone else smell it but i think
she put it in there
sienna tell the truth
i cannot believe that you were accusing
me of putting was i on camera because it
did it made me like
you were the one that discovered it
whoever smelled it dealt it oh yeah
[Laughter]
i was talking to michelle naomi saying
it's such a great group of
jesus
it's such a great group of brits in this
cast like it seems you all had a lot of
fun together the rhyme committed the
crime that's it not quite that it
said
i'm so sorry it's that time of the day
where it's silly o'clock we're both jet
lagged i know my husband he's a good man
i didn't do
what i'm accused of if i don't get some
order in my thoughts i don't know what
i'm gonna do
[Music]
such a huge part of her motivation is
protecting her children from various
forces throughout the different episodes
did you draw on your own instincts for
that what was that element of the
character like i mean in my experience
when you have a child
the instinct is to protect them from
everything and um so that kind of comes
naturally with being a parent i think
that her first response is how do i
protect the children from this which i
understand of course and can relate to
but yeah i don't really know what else
to add other than than i i understood
and sympathize with that part of her you
know she's doing everything to hold this
family together this family is
everything she's given her life to and
it's crumbling um and the children are
kind of innocent by players in a really
unpleasant plot although i think that's
actually one of the tragic bits is they
actually are a great family
[Music]